[Music]  hi there i'm stuart saint and i'm the  owner of milk and cookie on the high  street in margate for the fibre fest  we're doing a very special design cookie  called our custard cream cookie it's  huge and it's gonna be a fiver because  it's almost three cookies in one uh not  for the faint-hearted i absolutely love  fiberfest because what it does is  promotes the local businesses and  encourages people to choose us over a  big commercial business to help  keep us going help us survive and we've  all got through coving and the pandemic  and we're all going really strong and  this is just about making us stronger  boosting the towns and making them more  popular than ever